il profite chaque jour de l'extérieur
cet air de je fais partie des ajouts au
projet initial de cette nouvelle crèche
l'arche de Noé accueil quotidiennement
jusqu'à 60 enfants ce site fonctionne en
3 unité de vie
une unité de bébé et 2 unités de moyen
grand nous accueillons également les
assistantes maternelles pour les jardin
d'éveil ça permet d'avoir plus
d'interaction plus de possibilités de
rencontre d'échange quand la pandémie
nous le permis 17 professionnels sont
dédiés à l'accueil collectif les
assistantes maternelles disposant des
locaux et que leurs enfants pour
diverses ateliers
[Musique]
les enfants sont accueillis chez les
assistantes maternelles et elle prêt
viens ici pour faire des ateliers par
petits groupes
les ateliers sont organisés à partir de
9h30 jusqu'à 11h l'arche de Noé a ouvert
ses portes le 30 août dernier si tu es
dans les anciens locaux de la Protection
Maternelle et Infantile la crèche à
nécessité 2 ans de travaux on regroupe
les trois crèche regrouper la ville la
crèche de la rainette la crèche canopée
la crèche familiale et on augmente le
nombre de personnes qu'on a 23 berceau
en plus un projet de 3 million d'euros
par fait par la ville avec le
département Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la
région Île-de-France est la CAF le site
et aussi un lieu d'expérimentation
national avec des travailleurs en
insertion professionnelle